[Applaudissements]
un sondage autour de la table bako quoi
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire elle est
mariée et pas moi à quoi christian bale
lui allait pas mal oui alors vous vous
quand vous étiez en couple vous faisait
l'amour combien de fois par semaine par
exemple par semaine par jour le sexe et
la grille la cuisine mais je cuisine
très très bien le sens où je trouve je
voulais rentrer des boulettes et une
culotte je peux dire oui vous êtes là
vous êtes mal tombée via des chats quoi
qu'est ce qu'il vous mettez les boulets
de recul
[Rires]
gilles verdez vous posez votre question
vous herbe au soir cyril hanouna de
dauphiné libéré
parce que souvent possible avec la même
nom mais elle congrès mais ça va pas non
et on tend donc à l'esam était dingue ou
poire etle et gratuit oui ça beau
comédien ouest
[Applaudissements]
mais moi moi je regarde mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya ça va pas le faire ce soir là
vous isabelle mois deux fois par win
deux fois par semaine par ce même col
amélioré il bosse beaucoup
jeudi matin dimanche matin les vendredis
samedis matin dimanche attend dimanche
matin de ce qu'elle nous pas téléfoot
jeu avant le badminton ça met en
condition après si c'est ça qui peut
déjouer précise tous les samedis et au
je me lève à 3h du matin
semaine si l'on sait vendredi se dresse
au chat et le reste
valérie vous valérie avec patrick on
s'inspire à sion selon l'inspiration
médias trop personnelle grèce et ça
n'avait quoi ça dépend ça donne ça
dépend ça dépasse voilà oui alors
combien mais je me pose moi vous combien
non mais attendez moi je suis chef de la
bande moi je suis chef de la meute
non mais écoutez et sans rigoler comme
quand nicolas sarkozy va aller paroles
et des actes des uns est ce qu'il doit
poser des questions à david pujadas ah
oui eh ben je crois pas dit non mais
vous pouvez voir cette baisse ajoute m
une fois ça peut être quatre fois ça
peut être d'en moyenne basse donc ça
fait deux fois la moyenne américaine
fois par jour non mais non là c'est
brushing
mais dès ce jeudi que c'était plusieurs
fois par jour oui ça patauge n'est pas
performant ce matin
[Rires]
halladay s'est plusieurs fois par jour
oui c'est fou ça reste les garde pas les
commères du jour c'est catherine et
liliane du petit journal qui ont
commenté le prochain one man show des
frères bogdanoff regarde c'est ce que
j'ai appris des bogdanoff avait préparé
un van lanschot beau oui à deux ça peut
être intéressant un sur l'univers et
tout ça j'espère qu'ils vont jouer dans
le sud pourquoi tant qu'il joue un
manteau la ville de vote
le titre ou toi tes trucs super